from a very young age we learned that if
smart people work hard and grow up in a
reasonably nurturing environment success
would come eventually
but over time we realize that's not
necessarily the case
a very few people we know who are
intelligent and have a strong work ethic
have gone on to do notable things
the vast majority of people we know are
doing okay
unfortunately there are even those who
drift along unsure about what to do
there are a lot of factors when it comes
to success
whether it means having a fulfilling
career having great relationships or
staying healthy
being smart and working hard are
definitely part of it but there's more
at play than just these two factors
here are seven reasons why you might not
be finding success even if you're smart
and hardworking
reason number one you don't reach out to
new people
it's easy to stick to people you've
known for a long time
you know each other's histories and can
laugh at inside jokes together
the problem with old friends though is
that the same ideas are recycled over
and over again and you don't get to
learn new perspectives outside of your
bubble
it can be tough to reach out at first to
new people but starting small can help
aim for a low goal initially such as
introducing yourself to one person a
week
reason number two you are averse to
change being in the same environment for
a long time makes it hard to adapt to
something new
the good news is that change presents a
chance for opportunities and innovation
instead of resisting changes see how you
can make the best of them
always try to see a different
perspective
be open to new concepts and curious
about the world around you reason number
three you believe you deserve success
based on credentials
people that worked hard in school
are used to being at the top and told
how much potential they show
this seems good initially but there are
some negative side effects
i'm sure we all heard people claim they
deserve something because of their
intelligence or where they went to
school
they expect things to pan out
automatically because of their
credentials
sadly though life doesn't work like that
in the real world you don't get results
based on the work you put in
you that results based on the
combination of hard work strategic
thinking and some luck involved
you can increase that last factor by
working on the first two
reason number four you are not willing
to take risks
smart people often choose the safe route
they might follow the same path as their
peers or choose a career because it's
considered acceptable by their peers
while this guarantees a degree of
security it can be mundane
i hear so often from smart people that
they find their jobs unfulfilling and
that they want to do something else but
are afraid to do so
if you are thinking about branching out
into unfamiliar territory consider what
your life will be like decades from now
if you opt not to pursue something
will you regret it or will you be happy
with your decision reason number five
you can't commit to a decision
being smart and working hard can open up
numerous doors
unfortunately having too many options
can be as restricting as having few
choices
an abundance of choices makes it
difficult to decide what to do
as a result it's tempting to jump around
and see what suits you
i knew someone who attended numerous
graduate school programs one after
another
over 10 years later
she still can't figure out what to do
rather than dabbling in many endeavors i
suggest testing things out first
talk to other people and do the research
before making a big decision so that you
know whether or not an option suits your
personality and lifestyle
reason number six
you constantly go after whatever is
exciting at the moment
one thing i hear often from high
achievers is that they hate wasting time
smart people are all too aware of the
value of their time as time and effort
spent on one thing means that they could
potentially be missing out on something
else
while this is a strong attribute it also
means chasing the next big thing and not
following through
starting out in any field or endeavor is
tough and getting through the initial
obstacles requires patience
focusing effort on one goal yields much
better results in the long run than
going after one thing getting bored and
then going after something new
reason number seven you don't believe in
yourself
surprisingly smart people can
underestimate their own abilities
they are their own worst critic causing
them to believe that they can accomplish
as much as they can
smart people have high standards when it
comes to their work
whenever they work on a project they
tend to scrutinize and second guess the
final product this seems like a good
thing on the surface but it's often more
debilitating than helpful
perfectionism can hinder people from
progressing forward in their goals or
starting on anything in the first place
so instead of letting fears of what if
or i'm not good enough keep you back
from something new think of how you want
your life to look like years from now
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you inflate the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell
enjoy the rest of your day